warm air and tranquil seas are the cash
crops of Key West the fishermen are
vacationers and vendors sell conch
shells as souvenirs although it has
become a tourist town the island has
always been a place where things are
done just a little differently it's
known for its literature from Ernest
Hemingway to Tom Corcoran Key West has
always been a favorite setting for
authors the story of Key West is the is
the change from poverty from fishing
from Navy to tourism and ultimately a
great deal of wealth Leslie is also an
aficionado of the islands architecture
honk houses were basically bohemian
style and houses that were built with
two stories some of the old houses were
actually built with wooden nails because
they were almost all built by
shipbuilders the most visited House Key
West is probably that of the islands
best known writer ernest hemingway lived
here each year Key West holds its annual
Ernest Hemingway look-alike contest Rick
Kervin one at one year
well I say faith been dead for 40 years
they got to be better look at and living
in Key West Kervin has met some
interesting characters one guy with
English guy jumped into order at one
time to coach starting fish them out of
the harbor and ass and what he was doing
and he was swimming home and said it was
true that Key West is nice and easy
alternative entertainer la la belle says
this is the only place that you can
really be yourself when I said if you
fly in and see the wrist surrounded by
the emerald waters and with the jewel in
the middle of it well i think that the
gay people and the diversity of the gay
people would put the sparkle in that gym
and every day when the Sun begins to set
tourists gather at mallory square to
take part in a celebration it also
drives many of the islands most
eccentric individuals whether you're a
vacationer or a year-round resident you
can always look forward to spectacular
sunsets a place to relax smile and watch
the orange light fade away